- Best comic book adaptation...
- Oh, yeah.
- to film hands down.
- It's--oh, yeah.
- No argument.
- Oh, yeah.
Oh.
See you later, girls.
- All right.
- Oh, yeah.
Um, I know I'm in the minority
here, but I don't really like
the Christopher Nolan
Batman movies.
- [scoffs]
- I don't.
I really just feel like
they're...overrated.
Okay.
[all laughing]
Well, that's, um,
that's just an opinion.
You see, that's why
I prefaced it by saying,
"I know I'm in the minority."
Awkward.
[both snickering]
You know, what, no.
No.
Not really.
It's not awkward,
at least not until
you said "awkward."
Now it's awkward,
because of what you said.
Anyway.
Anyway, what?
Really, 'cause when you say
"anyway,"
then you have to follow it up
with an actual contribution
to the conversation
we're having.
- Yikes.
- No, look at me.
Look at me. Look at me.
There's no "yikes,"
and the reason why
there's no "yikes" is,
there's nothing scary
about this situation, okay?
It's a very low-stakes
situation.
- All right.
No, not "all right."
Come here. No.
Don't look at him. Don't look
at either of those guys.
Look at me, all right?
"All right," what?
'Cause after you say
"all right,"
you have to follow that up
with something.
Don't do it.
Don't look at them.
Do not look at them.
No--No.
Don't do it.
Tell us how you really feel.
Okay, you know what?
I'll tell you how I really feel.
Listen, I really feel
like you're an asshole
who has nothing interesting
to say.
So what--oh.
No. Don't.
No, don't look at them.
Turn your head.
Turn it.
Right here.
Tell me an opinion
that you have about something.
Just one opinion that you have
about anything at all.
Just share an opinion.
Anything. Share an opinion.
Share an opinion.
Share an opinion right now.
Just off the top of your head.
Share an opinion.
Anything.
Just one opinion,
that's all I'm asking.
Share one opinion right now.
- Share it. Share an opinion.
- Ah, ah, ah...
I don't have an opinion,
and that's why I just like
everything that everyone else
likes in pop culture.
[groans]
[sobs]
[sobbing]
Don't look at me.
Don't look at me!
[sobbing]
Okay.